well as winter approaches cases of Cova
19 are rising across Europe Eastern
Europe and the Balkans are seeing the
highest numbers and some countries and
cities are turning to lockdowns to pull
them back from the brink and Latvia has
the highest rate of new cases of any
European Union country with nearly 900
cases per 100 000 residents reported in
the last week the government imposed a
nationwide lockdown on October 21st the
first in Europe This Autumn now EU
members Slovenia and Estonia are also
considering lockdowns both of them are
also seeing a weekly case rate of over
500 per 100 000 people and in all three
of these countries only a little over
half of the population has been fully
vaccinated TW correspondent Terry
Schultz reports for us from the Latvian
Capital Riga the Latvian government
hopes this four-week lockdown will give
it time to curb the record-breaking
climb in infections and to convince more
of the population to get at least their
first shot if we do not have a spike in
the demand of vaccination during this
lockdown period then it's going to be
bad epidemiologist Nikita troianstas is
the country's vaccination coordinator he
warned authorities months ago they
weren't doing enough to prevent this
wave it will be a few days before it's
known whether the lockdown is enough but
that's too late to save hospitals and
health care workers from being
overwhelmed now every morning starts
with the trembling hands looking at the
numbers this entire hospital has been
transformed into a massive covid Ward
what would normally be the urology
department for example is now awaiting
patients with intensive breathing
problems this area used to be a Scenic
entrance hall literally overnight it was
was transformed into the latest overflow
Intensive Care Unit which communications
director yanita Weinberger says is
likely to be full within days it is an
enormous struggle to
to arrange all the plans which units
need more nurses from from which units
we can borrow those nurses but besides
the virus something else is spreading in
Latvia blame for how it got to this
point from almost zero infections three
months ago many people tell me the
Latvian government botched its Outreach
on vaccines particularly to the
russian-speaking minority which was more
hesitant to get the shot too little
accurate information too much
disinformation says parliamentaria
nikolai's cabanovs Latvian Russian
population
still is in the
information space of Russia because
last three decades Latvian government
made a very poor communication strategy
with this Slavic groups there was a lot
of of wrongful information actually lies
in social networks due to this Dr ilza
kreitzberger says some patients who had
always trusted her with their lives
questioned her recommendation to get
vaccinated adding to society's confusion
some doctors openly disagree with the
government policy I don't think we
should push anything in medicine but
Nikita troyanska says the only way
latvians will get out of this crisis is
to increase immunizations for those who
have been skeptical before to change
their mind and for those who have been
shy to decide to decide now
and now the government is adding more
pressure suggesting restrictions will be
lifted in November only for those who
got the shot
and we can take a look now at some of
the other developments in the pandemic
in Germany the Robert Hawk Institute is
warning about the rising number of
infections it's reported nearly 25
000 new cases and 121 deaths meanwhile
the Pacific island nation of Tonga has
reported its first ever case of covid-19
after a traveler from New Zealand tested
positive and South Africa is setting up
vaccination sites at polling stations
for next week's local government
elections